it's doubleheader friday that's right as
you look into the city now outside of
oracle park as we get ready for game one
of this doubleheader padres giants this
is the time of the year where you want
to see your team play well and they're
gonna have to play well because the team
that they're taking on is a very
talented
team all right on the hill tonight for
the giants in game one of this
double-headers will be the
the left-handed veteran tyler anderson
anderson is 30 years of age
and he's in his sixth year at the big
league level six to 215 pounder out of
las vegas nevada and when you take your
advance against him you're gonna see a
fastball that's gonna be low to mid 90s
more lows than mids he's also got a
change up which is really his bread and
butter he also throws a curveball and he
will cut and sink that fastball dates
278 15 home runs 41 runs batted in
lifted to left center field it's
starting to carry dickerson at the wall
and it's going to be dubon who takes it
away from dickerson here's hosmer giants
did not see hasbro
in san diego he'd broken a finger trying
to bunt
pop
solano
in the shadow of the light towers and
that'll end the inning
for the giants jason dickerson solano
coming up with chris paddock on the
mound making this 12 start watch for the
cutter this afternoon against the giants
the team can hit
266 average
high drive to right field battling the
sun is myers out there
winds going to knock that ball down as
well makes the catch it is blustery out
there
keep the feet moving in case you have to
make an adjustment one out and brings up
alex dickerson
this one is up the middle and by the
dive of t sin to center field
one out single for dickerson a ringing
single into center
two down dickerson still at first and
here's the veteran brandon belt
elevates and is called strike three wow
okay
now the first strikeout for paddock done
with one without a score here's will
myers no score
three pitches to myers but here's nola
this one is sharply hit into left field
for a base head
all the turns on that has a one out
single
first piece runner to reach for the
padres on the base hit by nola now one
on and jake cronenworth coming up
got him and cronenworth knew it guessed
wrong in the two-strike camp two down
nola at first and tommy fan
in the air to left field hit pretty
deeply back goes to bond that's gonna be
over his head one hop the wall
around comes nola he will score for the
padres it's an rbi double for tommy pham
and the padres strike first on top one
to nothing sherman longoria
batting here with flores at first
on the ground to second base cronenberg
flips to second for one and onto first
for two
nicely done great footwork by tatis
coming over the bag
at second and the 4-6-3 dp nicely done
brandon crawford
this is hit well into center field
grisham on the move look it up
out of here
and this game is tied
crawford sitting on off speed
gets exactly what he's looking for and
that'll bring up joey bart
swinging a miss and he strikes southward
to end the inning one one two trent
christian
he'll drive this one out towards deep
right center field back goes jastremski
at the wall and it's off the wall right
above the 415 marker he's headed for
third thinking triple throat goes that
way and he'll be safe sliding in and
that ball stays just in the yard and
here's hosmer
right back to anderson there's one
there's two
and anderson
gets out of it after grisham let off the
inning with a triple alex dickerson now
with ustremski on second nobody out oh
and two swinging a miss he went chasing
a change up that was about two feet
outside so the third strikeout for chris
paddock now the 2-2 pitch
this is sharply hit and is picked at
second base by chronoworth is throw in
time nice pick at second base by jake
bronerworth tied one to one after three
as wilmer flores stands in
hit high and deep into left center field
this one is way back it is out of here
and the giants take to lead he's done it
against paddock again see if joey bart
can pick up dubai and he struck out in
the second
on the ground and a base hit
right past hosmer and joey bart comes
through and the giants lead three to one
just past hosmer
full
body slam into this thing he has with a
fly ball to right and a double down the
right field line high and deep to right
it is
out of here
and into the water
and it's number 10 on the year
and welcome back water shot
cronenworth is over two
got him three pitches
right back same location
with the fastball
strikeout number four for anderson
two on
nobody out
tatiso for three
[Applause]
and that one is line to left field of
base hit over to cut it off as dickerson
coming around from second is profar he
will score and it's five to two first
and third nobody out and the tying run
coming up here in manny machado
that one is squibbed and the pitcher
will go to first base and he hits
machado with it
scoring coming around is grisham it'll
make it five to three first and third
and now hosmer drives one out towards
right center field back will go dubon
and he'll get there to make the catch
tatis will tag he will score and it's a
one-run game it's now five to four
so here's nola
dubois
ball game
[Applause]
they don't make it easy that's for sure